derek chauvin's treatment of george
floyd
did not follow minneapolis police policy
or principles
according to its chief recalling in
court
the first time he saw the video that
shocked the world
a community member had contacted me
and said chief have you seen the video
of your officer choking and killing that
that man
at 38th chicago
a day after seeing the video of george
floyd's arrest
he fired derek chauvin and three other
officers
in very unusual testimony as a
prosecution witness
against his own colleague chief
arredondo
said the forces number one value was
sanctity of life
it is my firm belief that the one
singular incident
we will be judged forever on will be our
use of force
and so while it is absolutely imperative
that our officers go home at the end of
their shift we want to make sure and
ensure that our community members go
home too
and so sanctity of life is absolutely
vital that that is the pillar
for our use of force derek chauvin's
restraint of george floyd was not
de-escalation he told the court then
came his damning verdict
of his former officers actions when mr
floyd was no longer
responsive and even motionless
to continue to apply
that level of force
to a person proned out
handcuffed behind their back um
that that in no way shape or form is
anything that uh
is by policy is not part of our training
and it is certainly not part of our
ethics or our values
george floyd's use of a counterfeit
twenty dollar bill to buy cigarettes
is not something that would normally end
in custody according to minneapolis
police chief
and the actions of the former officer
that followed did nothing
to try and save this man's life sally
lockwood sky news minneapolis